jana kramer reveals she suffered a  miscarriage the 34 year old singer took  to social media over the weekend to  share the tragic news with fans posting  this heart-wrenching photo visibly  crying and holding a sonogram captioning  the pic in part i don't want i'm sorry  or sympathy i just don't want to feel  alone and i know i'm not because we  don't tell many we have to suffer  silently and suffering silently was my  thing in the past but it's not now jana  also says this isn't the first  miscarriage she suffered writing today i  am one for three kramer shares  one-year-old daughter jolie with husband  michael carson jolie turns to next month  sad news comes just days after the  couple jetted off to Hawaii to celebrate  Kramer's 34th birthday  [Music]